nature reports on the remarkable
discovery of a female figurine in a cave
in southwestern Germany believed to be
at least thirty five thousand years old
I think culture and art was important
part of the life during that time and so
I think that gives a gives us a very
good view about the people and maybe we
we see the much closer to to out
ourselves
the discovery of the female figurine for
call the fells is really revolutionary
in the field it's the earliest find of
this kind that we have anywhere and it
really changes our image of how people
viewed their world about 35 or even 40
thousand years ago the site of houla
fells is in the arc valley fairly near
the current water level of the river and
it's a very prominent cave one of the
largest caves in the area readily
visible there's a long tradition of
archaeology in this valley at the moment
we are basically digging in our nation
and middle Paleolithic layers and our
first goal I would say is to get a
little bit more information how the
transition between the undertows and
modern humans went forward and what
happened during that time the site in
and of itself has a very prominent place
in the landscape and we think it would
have been used very early on in the
settlement history of the organization
the ordination is the first Upper
Paleolithic culture in our area the
middle Paleolithic precedes it is
characterized by Neanderthals and their
material remains and when modern humans
arrived in the area they create the
organization culture which has different
stone tools organic artifacts artworks
musical instruments in September we were
excavating in many squares in the really
bottom of the our nation layers and in
one square a student found a pot of
ivory figurines I actually was at a
meeting in frankfurt and maria molina
called me up and she said there was
something unusual coming up namely
fragments of what later became clear
were female figurine we cleaned the
figurine carefully documented the
surfaces did microscopic analyses glued
the figurine together
see we did was documented thoroughly
with photographs made a cast and now the
publication is coming out and the next
step will be exhibiting it in a major
exhibit plan for September in a museum
and struck out so what you can see is so
here's the complete arm and shoulder
coming across to the belly the large
breasts projecting forward and actually
very broad shoulders and you know head
of a thick torso the head is
conspicuously missing the vulva is
deeply incised the breasts are large
forward projecting and it's the sexual
characteristics of the figurine that
really were depicted with great care and
are the main characteristics instead of
a head there's a perforation that shows
it's a bit weathered but it also showed
signs of polish so it's completely clear
that the figurine was used as a pendant
taken at face value it seems that this
would be the oldest figurine from from
our region that in and of itself is
remarkably important because previous to
this we've found a lot of evidence for
working ivory we found lots of ivory
artifacts ornaments tools what we never
actually found a figurative
representation so that is new and shows
that figurative art was part of the
organization culture from the very
beginning in this region there's been a
hundred years of research on the meaning
of Venus figurines and I think at a
simplistic level it's clear that there's
a connection between sexuality and
reproduction and it changes our way of
looking at things and suggests that
reproduction fecundity are key parts of
what people were thinking about at that
time people were not just getting food
finding food hunting and so on they had
time to do to play music they had time
to establish art and so I think culture
and art was an important part of the
life during that time and so I think
that gives a gives us a very good view
about the people and maybe we we see the
much closer to two out ourselves
what we need to do in the coming months
years is try to complete the picture the
the left arm is missing in the left
shoulder we want to continue the
excavation into the area immediately
adjacent to where the other fragments
were found in the hopes of finding the
missing pieces we're talking about a
position that's about 20 meters from the
entrance of the cave we've been digging
here for many years and the organization
starts about two meters below the
current surface and now we're at a depth
about three meters below the surface so
we've gone through a whole meter of or
Ignatian deposits we need to get a
bigger area of excavation and get more
data in the context of the discovery to
make a better contextualized
interpretation to the picture of how
daily life was thirty five thousand
years ago I didn't even view it as
conceivable that this kind of find could
come from the organization up from the
base log nation the whole the whole
discovery really is truly exceptional
and came as an enormous surprise to me
and people I've talked to in the field
also are pretty much speechless about
this so we're going to have to process
this information for a bit and see how
things develop
you